Oh your facial hair yes how it looks
like Robert Downey jr. wcm can you guys
see it if you were just like make it
look like fresh and clean leave I mean
just shave off you believe the goatee is
that one yeah that's one who does not
have you ever tried that before I think
I tried it when Iron Man 3 came out yes
but I just look like well I look Mexican
but the hair is beautiful the hair yes
why I'm cutting that too
Oh what do you guys think check up my
hair I don't know no answer I don't know
yeah large answer yeah answer me or him
yeah trailer who watch that I forgot
about the judge here we go
no idea what this is about no I hope
maybe it feels like courtroom stuff
Judge Judy appears she's like a badass
with a gun
what'd you say oh that dudes hilarious
yeah
knowing every person you represent is
guilty it's fine and people can't afford
me he's gonna change over the course of
this movie oh yes is this the first time
Ramon passed away or is this something
you want all the cases you're about to
lose no grandpa Palmer's dead to me it's
like a figure of speech trust me nobody
wants to go to Carlinville
hey thanks for coming I'm sure your
mother would have appreciated hey Palmer
hey sheriff why it's regarding your
father
biggest mistake of your career you just
happen to run them over forensics found
traces of blood on your dad's car oh
[ __ ] on the bench in that courtroom for
42 years this was good actually period
we needed to establish a firm defense
there's no way here memory Oh she'll let
you
Wow from where he's your father
you mean now you granted you're signed
up with Nickel mr. Palmer I'm gonna
impale your client on the first-degree
murder charge you get a furnace my
father's a lot of fun touching things
you know there's no way I have memories
because sometimes you gotta forgive
for instance everyone else got an
Academy no wow perfect Halloween well
it's different I'm not entirely sure how
to feel about that yeah because it looks
like it could it looks like one of those
movies that could be a cheesy dramatic
script but the acting is really good
yeah you know like something about it
looks kind of like hey we want you to
cry and I felt bad I was like [ __ ] yeah
I mean I like good like I don't know
what those kind of sort of coming-of-age
coming night coming of age I don't know
oh there's a chick flick nobody yeah
maybe just coming to beige or it was
like a realization like oh shoot
something happened okay family stuff
does get to me they're like no yeah even
if the movies like corneas [ __ ] it's
gonna get to me I will get like a little
emotional I'm sure I'll cry a little bit
and this movie gets me to cry getting a
recommendation yeah movie moves you
that's good that's what's gonna happen
I'll be the judge of that I love that
pun mm-hmm bismi this deal mm-hmm you
face it a lot today we do we fist too
much use a little bit more fisting yeah
I agree
something about the business it's good
energy yeah like the make a sound
but yeah that's all the time I would
thank you for letting us know about that
trailer looks like a good family film
and Robert and your father looks really
good in it Nino and that's what really
counts yeah so if you're needed
Vera Farmiga she's [ __ ] great I love
her too she's good actually all those
actors are great yeah
even the Vincent dim for no guy good
movie yeah if you're near the channel
subscribe please
that'd be great full of me you also
subscribe to Jeremy's cuz you know he's
he's quite the Entertainer so I'm gonna
say check out his channel check out his
channel
it'll make you live a better life we'll
say I'll tell you that much yeah mm-hmm
this judge says yes oh god I can't wait
to watch this movie I love it
is there any good seats available wait
let me be the judge I'm waiting for like
three more judge jokes right now no dude
don't some of them will come up oh yes
so I'm gonna give a shout-out to a guy
named Eric Slusher he said Ryan JW don't
know what that means but do any of
wondering oh that's what it means I
think so yeah you type like this whole
paragraph but you can't write just
wondering JW but do any of the girls you
have on like Caroline Sally ever get mad
at some of the things you say or joke
about with them yes sometimes it's great
freaky number no no there are times
where they they get pretty upset I am
known to cross the line every now and
then and yeah especially with Sally
Sally is the easiest one to cross she's
got a little temper or a small one yeah
that's pretty scary I haven't seen that
yet no imagine that fire though Oh
someone told me the other day that I'm
disrespectful I don't have compassion
for Sally on this channel because it's
the way I talk about her hmm
so I'm gonna try to say this in an
appropriate way for you woman who
criticized me Sally I'm sure has a
wonderful genitalia area that my
genitals
would like to collide with through the
art of penetration
that's why I like to let her
emotions get riled up so she could take
out that energy on said [ __ ]
you be the judge of that yes and he
wanted to show the YouTube bros they
said never a YouTube channel said please
gonna have a shout-out and can I
subscribe to them I think I already did
subscribe you if I did it let me know
and he wanted to know and he wanted to
shout out too so here's your shoutout
check out their channel YouTube gross
boom the brothers not gonna lie not sure
what your channel consists of it's a
cool name I'll check it out for sure
check it out before I do and let me know
if it's worth checking out mm-hmm you
get the judge of that
yes vibe right yeah Robert delve out
Cuevas
that is awesome can you make a shout-out
in Spanish that will be great or at
least try me hombre shadow to see
Roberto de Valley Cuevas numero uno or
Joe wave is Ginga number do Bell Oh
Telemundo Alamo no desert then the
window no intention of a show
let's try to speak Spanish that's right
I look Spanish but up nice so don't
judge me I am to Roberto sorry man I
tried but I just started saying a bunch
of words I don't know okay I mentioned
you right you should be happy you're
lucky we mentioned you mm-hmm
hey you ever heard this joke well you
put them I don't know I what do you call
a Mexican with a rubber toe what
ah there you go okay that's good very
good that's a good icebreaker for the
ladies and big hi my name is Roberto
nice to meet you
right after you say the joke and then
BOOM then they'll ask what else is
rubber and then you can just play along
from there hmm
or you can just say why don't you be the
judge of that
wait let's see what else is rubber yes
like like this condom is that what
you're really